[Music]
with a strong cast and compelling
storylines it's no wonder why ncis has
managed to become one of the
longest-running scripted series in
television history the cbs mega hit just
wrapped up its 18th season
and the series shows no signs of slowing
down anytime soon there will be plenty
more crimes that require solving for at
least a bit longer
as the network has already picked up the
police procedural for season 19
but just because the show is coming back
doesn't mean that there
aren't going to be some major shake-ups
along the way the main cast members tend
to stick around for a while with actors
like mark harmon and sean murray being
there from the beginning
however other actors have jumped ship
over the course of the show's long run
with their characters moving on with
their lives to do something else beyond
investigating crimes
and that appears to be what's
transpiring with emily wickersham who's
played fan favorite character eleanor
bishop since season 11.
the season 18 finale saw eleanor
undertake a secret mission but it was
unclear to some fans whether she would
return or if this was the end
the actress took to instagram to confirm
her departure from the series writing
hanging this hat and jacket up what a
great ride it's been
it's awesome it's been it's been really
wonderful and fun
she genuinely seems to have enjoyed her
time on ncis and there doesn't appear to
be any bad blood between her and any
other cast members
in other words this doesn't seem to be
the kind of falling out that's alleged
to occur at the time of paulie parrett's
exit from the series
given the fact eleanor tells nick torres
she won't be back for a long time
it doesn't seem likely that bishop will
be coming back for any cameos anytime
soon with that unfortunate news in mind
here's everything you need to know about
why emily wickersham is leaving ncis
the actress announced her departure from
the series with an instagram post on may
26
2021 throughout wickersham's lengthy
comments on the matter she doesn't
mention anything about why she chose to
leave after season 18 of ncis
the most likely explanation is that she
merely wanted to pursue other
opportunities after playing the same
character across eight seasons and 172
episodes
i mean if we worked like regular nine to
five jobs things could be different
being free from the rigors of a network
show's shooting schedule would give her
flexibility in choosing other jobs or
even just taking a break for a while and
enjoying her hard-earned success
but what's most important for fans of
ncis is that it appears as though she's
leaving on good terms with everyone she
worked with
over the last decade they're loose like
the whole cast and cruise like lucy
goosey which makes for like such a nice
work environment it really does
as she mentions on instagram i've been
lucky enough to be a part of a show
where i got to show up and
act and laugh and learn with wonderful
people a moment in time i
surely won't forget thank you cbs and
ncis for including me in a part of
television history
as you go down her post you can see a
slew of comments from her many followers
have already come
in including one from the official cbs
instagram account which posted
thanks for making history with us
wickersham's co-stars including maria
bello and brian dietzen
also use their accounts to express their
pleasure of getting to work with her for
so many years
wickersham is now free to pursue
whatever projects interest her the most
from here on out while it's still
unclear where she'll end up
bright things are inevitably in store
for the talented actress wickersham's
co-stars aren't the only ones sad we
won't see any more of ellie bishop
eating snacks while putting clues
together ncis fans took to twitter in
droves to express their sadness at the
season 18 finale spelling the end of
ellie as well as the much-loved
relationship between ellie and nick
ellie bishop served as an inspiration to
plenty of viewers including one user who
raved about both her favorite character
and the talented actor who plays her
writing maybe some people will never
understand why i'm so devastated but i'm
31 years old i grew up with ncis but i
just connected with one female character
emily wickersham played ellie bishop a
powerful talented persevering and
empowered woman
others talked about how ellie had
impacted their lives beyond the small
screen
influencing the real world in a very
real way one person wrote thank you
emily wickersham for creating such an
amazing character
one that inspired me to pursue a career
in intelligence myself
fans will miss you but i think i speak
for all of us when i say there's only
one ellie bishop check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
for coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you